so annelise michelle had 67 exorcisms
67 and she my understanding was she was
a devout
catholic before she became possessed if
you will uh went to church
every sunday prayed
all the time i believe her knees broke
or
suffered serious injury because she was
praying so often
she had epilepsy she had a seizure when
she was 16
and went into psychosis so my question
to you would be now there's a very key
point in there where i think i believe
i've heard you say that people will
start to speak latin
like classic latin that nobody today
speaks
she doesn't at least not on camera
perhaps it was she did it just wasn't
recorded
how much of this could actually just be
attributed to her psychosis or
schizophrenia or epilepsy or what have
you like
my problem is i i do believe but i'm a
skeptic but like people equate this to
aliens and you can almost make the case
that aliens have more traction than
demonic possession especially today so
like what
obviously it's just a belief but like
why is this real why is this just not
epilepsy or schizophrenia
well they've got a couple comments i was
gonna make you know
the church has clear teaching on the
reality that evil is personified but a
lot of the things that we witness there
isn't any clear teaching on that
so like is she possessed by nero is she
possessed by judas
that would raise the question
can
the souls of the damned possess people
and so was that really
judas was that really nero
or where
hitler or whatever or were they demons
who were mimicking those personalities
as a way to feed into the audience if
you will because the gun the
the goal of any demon would be to sow
confusing confusion
to really just make things really hard
to understand and comprehend and
watching this
that's exactly what would happen
yeah um
i want to go back to the what's the
motivation here i'm zero percent
questioning your motivation however i am
questioning the motivation of the
catholic church
not sure if you've heard the news
catholic church hasn't exactly have a
great reputation these days the movie uh
spotlight all that stuff i'm not talking
about the kids and we won't go there but
i mean if we do whatever but not exactly
the best reputation these days but i'm
talking you're talking about motivation
and incentives maybe
uh you know
if the church
kind of promotes demons if there's no
demons maybe there's no devil
and if there's no devil maybe there's no
god so maybe
going down that path
it behooves the church to sort of
incentivize that there are in fact
demons and to go down the path of well
the demons the god you know the devil
and all that so i guess my question is
from a you asked about motivation what
incentivizes i'm not saying that it's
you
but there is seems to be an incentive
for the church to
promote
these demons or these exorcisms because
you know how would how else would you go
towards the path of god you know good
and bad type of thing if there's no
devil
i would say you know it isn't that the
church is promoting exorcism
the church is promoting
god i mean i don't go out and randomly
say to people on the street hey i think
you're possessed you need an exorcism so
it isn't that i'm going out and telling
people they need an exorcism it's people
that are coming to the church and then
out of a ministry of charity
the church will
look into what they believe to be the
case and then to weigh in on that now
ultimately
because the majority of people as i
mentioned have already self-diagnosed
if i tell somebody that i don't believe
that they're possessed
guess what they're going to find
somebody out there who's going to agree
with them people will continue to shop
around
until they get what they want
you want you said that you just wanted
to become a priest right that was your
motivation right that's really cool
but that's at the core of of
christianity is you know what did jesus
do in his life you read biblical
accounts and i would suggest that jesus
came to
destroy the devil
but i like the work of the church today
my question is pat said why would you
want to become an ex or an exorcist he
said we were like well i didn't really
want to become an extras i want to
become a priest and then you got a phone
call one day i assumed by the church and
they're like
you're up buddy we're going to need an
exorcist in indiana and you're the guy
and i assume you're not going to say no
to that
no because as a priest when you're
ordained you promise obedience to your
bishop exactly that's my point so
they're going to say hey time for you to
become the exorcist you say all right i
promise obedience so that's my new job
so it's part of you're not going to say
no
so like that's your job now so now it's
your job as an exorcist to go
do exorcism so back to my initial point
it's sort of like the churches
but even when you're pushing this upon
but even
but having that role
it's really up to me to determine
how to live that out
it's not that the bishop's calling me
every day and saying hey i expected you
to do 10 exorcisms today it really is
even when i got the appointment it's
really up to me to determine how to
live out that role i mean i could choose
to remain anonymous the bishop who
appointed me
he even encouraged me to help educate
people what the church believes and
teaches to to use it as a
an educative role if you will but again
there are some exorcists you can just
kind of stay off in the shadows and
nobody will even know who you are or
what you do and but the church is aware
you're out there doing podcasts and
putting putting this out there sure but
again and but it's a way to help educate
people and you know people can agree
with me they can disagree with me they
can agree with the church or disagree
but my goal is simply to present
take advantage of opportunities present
what the church believes what people do
with that is up to them i'm not offended
or i don't get
upset or angry it's just a matter of
saying this is what the church believes
i throw it out there what people do with
it ultimately is up to them so if you
like this clip and you want to watch
another one click right here and if you
want to watch the entire podcast click
right here